hello everybody my name is markiplier oh
say what
Sybil no I do WeDo
what you want Hill mi Oh mister Oh I
fell out of the world I'm falling whoa
where am i what what say what now can't
see anything it's dark I'm scared and
alone
oh there's zombies down here I can
barely see anything where am I going
holy crap wait a minute are these two
choice doors these are these are the
choice doors but it's all dark here it's
all dark wait a minute I'm going back to
my desk I'm going back to my desk what
do I got what do I got going on what's
going on here it's the original this is
the original layout Oh Oh Oh is the
original I'm gonna push so many buttons
ah I'm pushing out of buttons holy crap
I don't know if there's a point of this
hey mister man do you have anything to
say about this being you know how this
was the original layout of the game and
maybe you would have something that you
need to say about me and their sin
what's go oh I wonder what he found if
what he wanted was to be the leading man
in his own story well perhaps he's
gotten it down in wherever he is right
now I wonder if he's happy with his
choice and if he's learned the heavy
cost that comes with it he'll understand
soon what I was trying to tell him he
needs me someone who will wrap
everything up at the end to make sense
out of the chaos and the fear and the
confusion there
Who I am that is what I mean to this
world oh yes
yes I'll be back there's no other way
once this ends after it all comes to a
close then I'll be back the end will be
here soon very soon I can wait
you
oh nothing what the end is never the end
is never the end is never been dong say
wha
ah man alright fine
Stanley decided to shut up the meeting
room perhaps you simply missed a memo
fine fine whatever I'm gonna follow your
instructions now I'm gonna say I'm gonna
do what you tell me to when Stanley came
to a set yeah shut up and doors he
entered the door on his left yeah yeah
I'm going for it going the distance but
don't expect me to cooperate that much
from now on yet there was not a single
person here either
feeling a wave of disbelief Stanley
decided to go up to his boss's office
hoping he might find an answer there
mm-hmm let it ball up inside you take it
out passive-aggressively on other
co-workers present coworkers we're not
the board anymore well that's awesome ah
keeps a cool broom whoa yes way Stanley
stepped into the broom closet but there
was nothing here so he turned around and
got back on track how about no this
place looks really interesting I think
there's something here well yeah I'll
stay here for a bit there was nothing
here no choice to make no path to follow
just an empty broom closet yes or why
reason to still be hey hey if I want a
break from your nagging then I'm
undertake one excuse me sir just messing
with my tools here it was baffling that
Stanley was still just sitting in the
brew
he wasn't even doing anything shut up at
least if there was something to interact
with he'd be justified in some way yeah
yes he's literally just standing there
doing sweet FA oh that's beautiful
yes standing around doing nothing
yes boy please offer me some explanation
here I'm genuinely confused why not well
I mean I stand in a room all day pushing
buttons can I just do staying in a room
not doing anything well do you realize
there's no choice or anything in here
right yeah
if I'd said Stanley walked past the
broom closet at least she would have had
a reason for exploring it to find out
yeah but it didn't even occur to me
because literally this closet is of
absolutely no significance to the story
what so ever yes oh I I never would have
thought to mention it it's my story
I make it a part of my story how these
broom may be to you this is somehow its
own branching path maybe when you go
talk about this with your friend you'll
say oh did you get the broom closet
ending the broom closet ending was my
hey guys I'm gonna find the broom closet
ending dance mom was fat and ugly and
really really stupid he probably only
got the job because of a family
connection that's how stupid he is that
all with drug money also Stanley is
addicted to drugs
no no to Trish well I've come to a very
definite conclusion about what's going
on right
you're dead after this broom closet
exploded a bit and we're just about to
leave because there's nothing here when
a physical malady of some sort
shut down your central nervous system
and you collapse on the keyboard oh yes
well in a situation like this the
responsible thing is to alert someone
nearby so as to ensure that your body
has taken care of before it begins to
decompose yes hello anyone who happens
to be nearby the person at this computer
is dead or she has fallen prey to any
number of your Cutlass human
physiological vulnerabilities yes it's
indicative of the long-term
sustainability of your species yes
please remove their corpse from the area
and instruct another human to take their
place at the computer making sure they
understand basic first-person video game
mechanics and filling them in on the
history of narrative tropes in video
gaming yes so that the RNA and
insightful commentary of this game is
not lost on there yes all right when
you've done that just step out into the
hallway
fine now play by your rules ah second
player it's good to have you on board
guarantee you can't do any worse than
the person who can't wait for you Wow
Gibran closeted you to unbelievable
I'm at the mercy of an entire species of
invalids perhaps there's a monkey nearby
you can hand the control look you can
hammer out the details I'm not
particularly picky I'll just be waiting
for when you're ready to pick up the
story again okay okay alright we're
gonna do what he says nope we're gonna
go up we're gonna go onto a staircase
Stanley walked upstairs to his boss's
office yes to the boss what yeah I wanna
go in the executive bathroom hey boss
boss Ken can stepping into his manager's
office
Stanley was once again stunned to
discover not an indication of any human
life he's shocked unraveled
Stanley wondered in disbelief who
orchestrated this what dark secret was
being held from him the narrator he
could not have known was that the keypad
behind the boss's desk were guarded the
terrible truth that his boss had been
keeping from him I saw and so the boss
had assigned it an extra secret pin
number two eight four five but of course
Stanley couldn't possibly have known
this give him credit and by simply
pushing random buttons
Stanley happened to input the correct
code by sheer luck
Oh wheezing Wow into the newly opened
passageway
oh right cool Bartowski
oh hi where is this gonna go where are
we going are we going boss I've wanna
know
descending deeper into the building
Stanley realized he felt a bit peculiar
it was a stirring of emotion in his
chest yes though he felt more free to
think for himself to question the nature
of his job maybe did he feel this now
went for years it had never occurred to
him hey this question would not go
unanswered for long well why but why oh
this looks rather sinister Danny walk
straight ahead through the large door
that read mind control facility it's
copy Mindy I'm going this way
screw you buddy over this passageway had
the word escape written on it the truth
was that at the end of this hall Stanley
would meet his violent death yeah right
yeah whatever wait you telling the truth
he's just digging with me the door
behind him was not shut Stanley still
had every opportunity to turn around and
get back on track no how about now at
this point
Stanley was making a conscious concerted
effort to walk forward yes and willingly
confront his death yes yep yep yep yep
yep my death my death my death my death
whoop I may have died I'm not sure whoa
Wow say one now
as a machine word into motion and
Stanley was inched closer and closer to
his advice reflected that his life had
been oh no consequence whatsoever Oh
Stanley can't see a picture he doesn't
know the real story that forever in his
narrow vision of what this now perhaps
it's death with a loss now plugging the
eyeballs from a blind man no so he
designed and willingly accepted this
violent end to his brief and shallow
life
farewell Stanley cried the narrator as
Stanley was led helplessly into the
enormous metal jaws in a single visceral
instant Stanley was obliterated as the
Machine crushed every bone in his body
killing him instantly
and yet it would be just a few minutes
before Stanley would restart the game
back in his office as alive as ever what
exactly did the narrator think he was
going to accomplish when every pass you
can walk has been created for you long
in advance death becomes meaningless
making life the same do you see now do
you see that Stanley was already dead
from the moment he hit start oh my oh oh
I've gotten cross-eyed Oh God
what is happen what is go on what is do
oh yeah
alright then this is strange Hey look
the credits good job everybody from
making it and Kevan brighting your great
narrator I'm so confused oh boy oh wow
for the freedom ending in the alpha what
Caillou
what oh my goodness gravy I am soaking
first I am so confused
I am so confused
Wow I guess this is just a buying the
scenes of all the stuff that can happen
it's so cool
what this game how much is there of that
I do not know oh oh wow I haven't even
scratched the surface a by oh my I have
not even come close to finding the end
of this game oh say what
Oh God
my brain is officially used out my ears
I have no idea what's going on anymore I
really don't I didn't even know where
I'm going from now to here what is doing
you on what I don't know I don't know
what's happening how do I even get to
wait I was on that was on hang on a
second okay I'm going to the exit I'm
out of here
oh look at these two how they wish to
destroy one another how they wish to
control one another how they both wish
to be free can you see can you see how
much they need one another no perhaps
not
sometimes these things cannot be seen
and listen to me you can still save
those two you can stop the program
before they both fail push escape and
press quit there's no other way to beat
this game as long as you move forward
you'll be will pick someone else's path
stop choice don't choose it time
I'm gonna die Philly's gonna die
oh no this is Oh God my brain is so full
of what ah God I have no idea what's
going on anymore my brain is broken I
have been broken I don't know anymore
I don't know but I'm gonna play again so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation with more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next week
haha